nouveaux logements nouveaux commerces
nouveau commissariat le secteur des
quatre arbres connaîtra dans les
prochaines années un profond remaniement
à elancourt en vaste chantier qui
pourrait entraîner un déménagement de
l'association des jardins familiaux
présente ici sur ce terrain public
depuis 1977 avec ses soixante six
parcelles
une phase de concertation est en cours
avec la population mais pour
l'association la municipalité aurait
déjà fait son choix les jardiniers sont
aperçus quand même depuis 2018 que la
municipalité ici si vous voulez on
vendait les terrains à des promoteurs
pour construire des logements pour donc
ramener de l'argent évidemment pour
réaliser des dépenses municipales
si on a réussi à supprimer d'abord les
jardins familiaux on aura ainsi
l'opération donc nous voulons rester sur
place et cultivé au coeur des
inquiétudes une délibération présentée
en décembre dernier lors du conseil
municipal avec un projet de jardin
partagé
là où il ya une mauvaise interprétation
ses parents pour nous une volonté de
détruire de supprimer les jardins
familiaux sache jamais été notre idée
nous sommes ouverts à toutes discussions
monsieur le maire à cause de les
rencontrer et aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'il ya une attente une demande de
jardins familiaux de jardins partagés
également sans que les emplois sont
encore en attente et notre réflexion est
aussi sur sa septième il n'y a pas que
cette association qui a droit d'exister
il ya deux heures pour thoiras similaire
au comptoir il faut qu'on prenne en
compte leurs demandes et leurs besoins
une réunion des changes est annoncée
dans les prochaines semaines dès que les
conditions sanitaires le permettront la
refonte complète du quartier pourrait
ensuite débuté en 2026